on online at home we cannot wait to show
you what we have today and I can promise
you it's more interesting than a
keychain Oh too soon maybe too soon I
don't know up in the balcony are you
guys ready
[Applause]
all right everybody everybody at home
are you ready yes yes we're just gonna
assume that they're ready well if you're
ready for the biggest gaming biggest joy
in gaming and let's start this [ __ ]
let's do it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cook do you hear me Roger
[Applause]
after eating your miraculous space chili
no idea what you mean
our food is healthy captain to crew dead
monkey in the crow's nest I repeat
monkey down Spanky strikes again ha P
that captain a page where we could use
your space jelly to overclock our
engines
negativo me amore only you can melt my
circuits keep laughing fools the king
brilliant
- good cookin is love
[Music]
Engineering to officers we are dead in
the water
I repeat dogs come in what have we got
together Chuck [ __ ] nada
I hate white I see something
three o'clock starboard it is massive
but get back here Sonny
hold off
look down the bay
[Music]
gods protect us
Jade
[Applause]
thank you
fine
hello I'm Gabrielle Schrager narrative
director and I'm Giovanni senior
producer we are so happy to be back this
year to share our progress on our space
opera beyond Guerneville - a game full
of wonder emotion danger and high-stakes
drama last year you all saw the
enigmatic green eyed captain bikini
leading the legendary crew of the god on
a quest to discover the location and the
mystery behind a deep-space artifact
known as moksha
but the kini has since gone missing
Shanny is now captain of the gather and
she's leading a crew into the deep
unexplored space beyond system 3 when
they come face to face with their
nemesis fans will have recognized a
ferocious young Jade and Paige's back as
the incorrigibles efj cook of the gada
we've got two other officers uma the
holistic chief medic and Callum our
chief engineer and all of these
legendary characters will be playing a
major role in our prequel today we are
proud to represent our growing
production team in Mobile Barcelona
Bordeaux and Sofia thanks everyone for
making it happen
[Applause]
and thank you for them we'd be in BG -
you're a space pirate captain in a
distant galaxy near the end of the 24th
century at this year's e3 we will be
showcasing a new behind closed doors
demo offering a first look at our major
location the sacred city of Ganesha now
let's take a look at our first free
alpha gameplay footage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Ganesha is a metropolis filled with
sacred temples beautiful gardens and
bustling shops but it's also a darker
underworld rife with dirty bars and
dangerous back alleys our game is an
action-adventure RPG that you can play
alone or with your friends in coop from
the intimate interior of a hidden temple
to the very edge of the galaxy fight on
the ground and in space at massively
different scales and all of this
seriously what you will be seeing at e3
this year is only a very small part of a
much larger open universe we are
creating a universe we are also building
with our fans yeah let's go with beyond
gravel to we want our community to
participate in a way that's never been
done before through the space monkey
program we want our fans and people all
over the world to really be a part of
creating the game so today we are
issuing an open invitation for people
all over the world to contribute their
ideas music art works and create
original content that players will
experience as they explore the world of
beyond gravity and there is literally a
universe of ways for artists to express
themselves from giant frescoes to murals
street art music radio content and much
more to do this we have partnered with a
company at the forefront of community
collaboration hit record and here to
tell us more is their founder Joseph
gordon-levitt
[Applause]
thank you
I love this theater so thanks thanks to
you guys thanks Chioma and and thanks
Gabriela it's really good to be here I'm
super excited to do this for those of
you don't know hit record is this thing
I've been making for a long long time
it's really dear to me and it's a place
where people all over the world work
together on short films or music or art
all kinds of projects this is the first
time we're making stuff that's going to
go into a video game so it's a little
bit different than other like creative
platforms that you can find on the
internet because the point of hit record
it isn't just to post and promote stuff
that you've made on your own the point
is to collaborate so like when we're
making music for Beyond Good and Evil 2
it's not just gonna be a thing like a
contest where people submit songs and
then we pick one or two of them when we
put them in the game we're gonna be
really making the songs together and the
same goes for the visual assets that
we'll be creating
so whether you're a writer a musician
and illustrator if you're a pro level
artist or if you're just someone who
really cares about beyond good and evil
in that world and you love it and you
want to be a part of it there's gonna be
ways for you to contribute our first
creative challenges are live as of like
now someone's at my office pushing the
button like very nervous but you guys
you're doing great and yeah so come to
our site check out the Beyond Good and
Evil 2 page at hitRECord org and that's
it go do that [ __ ] thanks
[Applause]
[Applause]
hit records approach to community
collaboration is inspiring and were
incredibly happy to be working with
Joseph Emma's team and we really can't
wait to see what the community creates
so let's do it we will be showcasing
some of this content out our very first
dedicated community event the BG Fest
which will take place in Montpelier this
fall
thanks everyone have a great three
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up everyone my name is Justin
Kruger community developer on Rainbow
six siege and I'm here today to talk
about our community our community that
inspires us and drives us every single
day the siege team back in Montreal has
actually been so inspired by seeing all
of the millions of people playing our
game every single day over the past
two-and-a-half years we've actually
absolutely loved seeing our community
grow and I'm excited to announce today
that the Rainbow six siege community is
now 35 million players
[Applause]
yes thank you
I wish I could hug every single one of
you but I don't know if my arms are big
enough to hug every single one of you
and that would take a long time as well
as you can see because the community
grows so does the game and as you can
see behind me team rainbow has recruited
the Italian GIS operators maestro and
alibi actually this image represents ten
seasons forty operators and 19 maps that
is all free in-game and if you want to
get to know all these guys a little bit
better you can play operation Parabellum
which is playable right now and if you
want to see them in action at the top of
their game tune in to the Rainbow six
siege Pro League kicking off on June
18th at 5 p.m. Pacific time the world's
biggest eSport teams will be competing
for six months of intense Rainbow six
action and that's just one of the many
ways to enjoy competitions for Rainbow
six the sixth major is just around the
corner and will be hosted in Paris this
August our pro league finals will then
take us to Brazil in November yeah
Brazil and then the 6th Invitational
will once again be the pinnacle of
Rainbow six taking place in Montreal in
February 2019 yeah so whether you're a
player or just a fan of eSports there
really is no better time to get into
Rainbow six eSports and with the growth
of the game the community and the
eSports teams we wanted to take a moment
to reflect on some of our most
influential players today I'm excited to
unveil a sneak peek at an upcoming
documentary that is focused on a few
familiar faces who took their love for
siege to the next level without further
ado here's the first look at another
mindset
[Applause]
that is like the greatest injury to ever
happen to me well because it brought
siege to me I've been doing this for
what since year one season one right my
knife failed failed failed failed and
then finally we start succeeding yeah so
that's what we're gonna do we're gonna
come back
[Music]
they say be also here's my library
mamasan he's Jewish persuasion cabina be
obedient oh so there's a bidet
[Music]
esposa de todos vamos on the intruder
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
Royals is all about grassing with style
and getting up again
hello I'm until the sir creative
director of trials and also prime
minister of Finland now I'm pleased to
announce the trials is back and it's
bigger than ever
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just a
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry about that
trials rising takes you around the world
to iconic locations you never write
along and competition is everywhere but
competition is nothing without the
players and our community has always
been without of trials in rasterizing we
work with our players more than ever to
explain more
let me introduce Pratt Hill also known
as Professor fat Jerry
[Music]
you made a mess well thank you auntie
and hello everyone say I don't tha down
the front I see you I became a fan of
trials because it's challenging but so
rewarding when you overcome something
difficult but I soon realized that a
number of playable players struggled
with the harder levels so in 2013 I
created the University of Trials a
YouTube channel dedicated to mastering
trials writing now before I go on
ubisoft star players i want you guys to
make some big noise right now all right
well five years ago I was a star player
just like them but when red Leafs began
work when trials rising they approached
me to design and create all of the
tutorial content within the game it has
been an amazing experience for me but I
wasn't the only one involved 20
community members known as the trials
elite but there have been involved in
the development of this game for the
last two years whether they were track
builders streamers or speed runners each
brought something special to help shake
this game now if you want to get
involved register online at trials
game.com for a closed beta happening
later this year
[Applause]
let's go hey hey hey you don't we're not
gonna put a big coming soon off here
I think people gonna want another
release date yes you're right
right after I see we released on
February 20 1918 for Xbox one PC and the
first time ever also needed a switch
[Applause]
if you are III come to our booth and we
saw what trials is about crashing with
style and getting up again let's get out
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
my name is Jillian Garrity and I'm the
creative director on Tom Clancy's the
division - on Black Friday a strain of
the smallpox virus was released on
dollar bills in New York City the
infection and chaos spread across the
nation seven months later the virus has
mostly burnt itself out but America is
tearing itself apart Washington DC is at
the heart of this battle under constant
threat from dangerous factions civilians
are trying to rebuild in their survival
lies the seed for the rebirth of society
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
by the rules and there will be
conscripted will be made keep still
[Music]
[Music]
you are the last line of defense for
those civilians and for the country if
you fail history will be written by
tyrants
if you succeed history will remember the
few brave heroes who fought to save a
dying nation this setting lays the
groundwork for a compelling story based
campaign in which your actions have a
clear impact on the lives of civilians
in the division to Washington DC must
prepare for the greatest threat it has
ever encountered to face it
you and your fellow agents will need to
bring your equipment and tactical
abilities to the next level once agents
reach the end of the main campaign it's
time to select a new progression path by
picking a specialization it starts with
the choice of a signature weapon
powerful and unique weapons that
complement the rest of your equipment as
you progress with your specializations
you will not only grow in power but also
unlock additional tools and abilities
including exclusive versions of skills
specializations enable you to truly
complete your own personal play style
but also to synergize with other players
and take team play even further speaking
of teamwork I'm excited to announce that
for the first time eight players will be
able to partner up to face the ultimate
endgame challenge raids are coming to
the division
[Applause]
we learned a lot we learned a lot from
working on the first game and with the
division - we're launching with plans
for years of frequent major content
updates today we're ready to outline our
plans for year 1 we will be launching 3
DLCs in the form of episodes each one
will bring new story new areas to
explore and new activities and the best
part all of these episodes will be
completely free for every
[Applause]
where's my division team stay tuned
after the Ubisoft conference for an
exclusive 30-minute deep dive into a
playable III demo during our post show
as you can see they're getting ready
right now and they'll be playing right
after the conference is done until then
remember this is history's defining
moment hope for the future lies in you
agents of the division thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
becoming
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hi I'm zippy Manzano as sleep bruiser
and it's an honor to be back here
one year after we announced for the
first time and released the game it was
incredible so as a team I just wanted to
thank all of you for the support and all
the feedbacks received thank you
so we also started a year ago to work in
a brand new adventure and with a brand
new hero as well one that we cherish and
we love Donkey Kong so for today we
wanted to celebrate the upcoming release
of the Donkey Kong adventure and what
better with music than with grant
kirkhope our composer and the band
critical hits
so please enjoy thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
I did not know they had changed her
entrance challenges every day every
second
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right boy
it was over
god knows what town
against
[Music]
Universal
for sure - sure
we saw that was no
when you smoke
they would have it the tide turned in
our favorite game
a new way to turn our backs blowing up
straight
there was only one
trust us
[Music]
cooee
Empire now it was also
enemies became friends as friends became
enemies didn't trust anybody
at the top of the food chain
[Music]
[Music]
hunts in packs
[Applause]
all of Skull and Bones there are
soulless empires there are greedy
trading companies and of course ruthless
pirate games sailing the seas but there
are no heroes hello my name is Justin
Ferran creative director at Ubisoft
Singapore and for the past year my team
and I have been anxiously awaiting at
this moment to invite you our fans to
join the hunt here at e3 2018 piracy is
dead in the Caribbean
the Empire is crushing all those who
oppose them so your next big score the
Indian Ocean home to the richest trade
routes in the world where merchant ships
carry cargo worth over 10 billion
dollars a year and you you're gonna
steal every last [ __ ] coin first you
need a target you pick up intel on a
heavily guarded frigate fat with african
diamonds mid for the grand mogul of
india that treasure will help you claw
your way to the top to become d pirate
that no empire can take down second you
must know your hunting ground are
reactive an evolving world is reflected
in what we call fortunes presented to
you by tallied the fortune teller now
fortunes reveal changes in factions
weather and the trade routes themselves
today tell gene reveals favorable winds
that means more merchants to rob but
also more competition and now I'm proud
to share with you the essence of Skull
and Bones a shared world where every
player encounter matters will you fight
or will you ally this is what we call
the hunting grounds alright pirates
let's head to the hideout and have a
great III
[Applause]
boy starts here in your highness a
classic
this hidden pirate den provides
everything you need for your next strike
from your shipyard you choose the black
porn for the upcoming
the strong winds will boost its speed
giving his pattering rhyme a devastating
punch next which is the right crew and
gear for the mission ahead demi cannons
are slow loading but deadly at short
range
rockets are blazing fast ideal powerful
damage from every angle with everything
loaded let's head out
the winds are strong in the day is clear
that mean more merchants to other but
also more rival pirates I'm looking for
a quick score
according to your Intel the convoy is
selling past a portuguese fort taking
advantage of the strong winds that fort
is too strong to simply sail past its
cannons can blast you out of the water
you need to find a way to sleep by
before the convoy slips away
fortunately deception is another tool in
the pirate arsenal let's follow these
black guards
disguised as a Portuguese merchants you
tried to creep past the fort captain if
we engage they will see it through our
guys
oh geez this island provides perfect
cover for a surprise attack
plots the optimal cost for an intercept
reading your sales for speed we want to
catch your victim off-guard
she bad
ships traded to the border
what God is
while we did
Watership cited Portuguese frigate I'm
your attack that alerted a powerful
Portuguese warship at the helm is a
Commodore too tough to handle on your
own
even worse you could lose your loot
you need help and you need it fast
other captains of anti-joke or four
against one should even the odd
your site forms a tight squadron using a
coordinated battle plan
the enemy strikes first
the first ship goes down breaking a
formation
turns his cannons over here a sapphire
solving the first blow
allies maneuver opposition the royal
fortune acts as a tank drawing the
Commodores fire it unleashes its special
ability the siege mode once anchored he
can fire its cannons without limits
Jaeger slipped into position that is
powerful
it's special ability delivers eight
shots in a single blast
it's up to you to land the killing blow
is one
but the glitter of gold can turn new
allies into deadly enemies
for there is no honor among thieves
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
to the digital space
let me see
[Applause]
hello everyone my name is Elijah Wood
co-founder of Spectre vision that were
known for our film content were also
avid gamers and the opportunity to
partner with Ubisoft was something we
had to be a part of and my name is
Benoit tree game director on
transference together
we combine a storytelling techniques of
film with interactivity of video games
enabling us to create this unique deep
immersive world with a dark and
unsettling narrative have you ever
dreamed of entering someone else's
consciousness exploring their darkest
thoughts and most intimate secrets in
transference and with transference we're
bringing no with trans friends are
bringing a first-person exploration game
into a chilling new dimension to escape
you must go hands-on to search for clues
solve puzzles while shifting between the
perspectives of each family member and
attempt to piece together the mystery
this fall in VR and on traditional
platforms we welcome you to uncover the
secrets hiding in this mind-bending
psychological thriller that will leave
you with haunting memories long after
you put down the controller this is
transference
here's mom you're gonna see here real
okay just hold still please
sighs are you comfortable I know this
rigs a bit cumbersome but that's always
the way with these young prototypes huh
and all you have to do is just just be I
know things haven't been so great lately
okay I've been a lousy father I'll
enable lousy husband too if you're gonna
sleep you've seen her run that's gone
[Music]
but all that is gonna change
we're all gonna be together all of our
hard work reverse the process all of our
sacrifices that's my gift to you
dad why are you doing this I love you
[Applause]
I have waited so long for this
we will sacrifice
fully waiting for it let's get out there
go show the most darling can do
the Legion is growing there aren't
enough of us we need to find help from
every planet in atlas
[Music]
the more of us there are the stronger
each of us is exactly
you must feed my lead
Drax isn't going to stop until we end
this
I will finish this
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you hello everyone I'm Laurel
Melville creative director on storing
battle for Atlas last year revealed our
muderer starship innovation to the world
and showed you how players could
reconfigure it instantly to adapt to any
challenge this year we're excited to
show you what the or the depth of the
open world that was built and put the
game directly into your hands we're
going to take you on a journey 400
light-years away from Earth to the Atlas
star system discover exotic planets meet
fascinating local factions and forge
your Alliance upgrades your pilots
starships and gear and unleash
devastating combos to save at last from
the relentless forgotten nature the
mission will not be easy Atlas is a
dangerous place and our heroes will need
all the help they can get
could use a little help here
[Music]
you hear me
rock-and-roll boys
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone it is an honor to welcome
starfox installing battle for Atlas
isn't it oh it's amazing
ever since I started working on Starling
I wanted to invite Fox and his crew into
the game and Star Fox on Super Nintendo
was the first 3d game I've ever played
I'll never forget that and so for me
this moment is a dream come true and
this dream was only made possible thanks
to our long relationship with Nintendo
we can't wait to play fox under Nintendo
switch I would like to give you to give
a special thanks to a dear friend with
wizards in the audience today ladies and
gentlemen mr. Miyamoto
[Applause]
how are you
[Applause]
I know you were coming today so I came
with a gift you know it's the first
prototype of the vessel that you
research so do you like it super so
thank you very much so it is actually a
vessel that has been created by the team
and they would be so happy to see you
backstage so let's go and join them
thank you
Thank You mr. Miyamoto and thank you Eve
for everyone at e3 please be sure to
come by the Ubisoft booth where we'll
have a full hands-on demo for you to try
for everyone else
Starlin will launch on all consoles on
October 16th with Star Fox as an
exclusive Nintendo switch experience
[Applause]
thank you
thank you
thank you so much checkout starting game
come to pre-order the game right after
the conference thank you so much for
being here today and have a great
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
dreamers cosplayers artists tournament
organizers and all of our players you
are for honor
hello I'm Ramon Campos Iola creative
director whether it be upgraded
stability with the dedicated servers
release of Heroes constant balancing and
new training tools we would not be here
without your passion and commitment
you've helped us enrich the experience
thank you but actions speak louder than
words right
in celebration of III we are inviting
new players to join so if you haven't
played for honor yet now is your chance
starting today and until next Monday we
are giving away the PC starter edition
on you play downloaded this week on PC
and it's yours for free
[Applause]
join the fight with us
[Music]
but that's not all because building on
everything that we've learned we are now
ready to expand our world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
waiting for them something
[Music]
kisum
classroom
[Applause]
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
after the great Cataclysm that brought
Knights Vikings and samurai to fight
civil war consume China warriors of the
Wulin factions fought each other but
failed to establish order amid the chaos
for warriors of the ruling no March West
with the new faction four new fighters
visual enhancements and single-player
concerns yet to be revealed the marching
fire update is our biggest and most
ambitious additions of our but this
update would not be complete without
answering a huge request from our
community a new 44 multiplayer mode
fulfilling the classic medieval fantasy
know what it is the castle siege so
please allow me to introduce you to this
new mode bridge
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone I'm Delphine dosa brand
director on the creature in just a few
days freedom will be yours freedom to
get your hands on your dream car bike
boot or plane and unleash your passion
for motor sports all across the United
States
the creature releases on June 29th and
we are very happy to announce that the
open beta will be available on
PlayStation 4 Xbox one and PC on June
21st but there's more
you can pull of the open beta right now
so you'll be ready to hit the road as
soon as it starts from all of us at I
reach our welcome to the crew to
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
how can a child save us all if he's
sentenced to die
tell me Nicholas tell me before you let
our son go
where we begin does not define who we
will become before you I see a bar
built by friendship
family love and loss war and bloodshed
by the gods to protect this world
you carry the blade of yumminess
act like it
as you write your oversee across the
mountains and the Seas
the fate of Greece journeys with you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you thank you I'm Jonathan Simone
creative director of Assassin's Creed
Odyssey Assassin's Creed Odyssey is more
than just an adventure it truly is a
role-playing journey you will explore on
land and see one of the most iconic and
influential settings in human history
ancient Greece the Golden Age of Athens
saw the rise of democracy
modern medicine revolutionary art and
Western philosophy but it was also a
time of war a devastating conflict
between Sparta and Athens the
Peloponnesian War divided the Greek
world and changed the course of history
in this world of contrasts and
opportunity this land shaped by the gods
rage is a battle between order and chaos
this is where your adventure begins you
a simple mercenary an outcast to take on
an incredible quest to save your loved
ones and become the legendary Greece
Greek hero Greece desperately needs our
teams in Quebec and from around the
world I've spent the last three years
putting all their energy passion and
dedication into this project we have
continued to transform assassin's creed
into an epic RPG experience an RPG in
which you will not just play an odyssey
but your Odyssey shaped by your actions
and choices
and the first choice you'll make had the
start of the game is to choose your
character panic sills or Cassandra
and you played a character for the
entire game you share the bloodline of a
legendary Spartan hero and bear as
mysterious weapon
your turn
[Music]
there need a spear you're old enough now
my father's spirit holds certain burden
but you are ready think of Leonidas he
can create courage and he made a great
sacrifice you share his blood and
strength he possessed
the broken sphere of Leonidas gives you
access to powerful ranged combat and
stealth abilities that you can unleash
on your enemies
and for the first time we have deeply
changed the way we tell stories in
Assassin's Creed you can now truly
interact with history like never before
perhaps when I was thin up both in
weight and philosophy so tell me were
you able to resolve the situation
without bloodshed the rebel heart guards
I relieved them hmm interesting
you thought the life of a thief and a
murderer was worth more than that of
soldiers doing their duty I wasn't even
thinking about him to be honest and what
of the rebel
[Music]
he should be halfway to Mykonos by now
oh really
you let that lunatic run loose are you
sure that was wise I'm not sure if
watching you was wise our choices are
like ripples on water they seem tiny and
insignificant at the beginning but they
can become devastating tidal waves by
the time they run their course
[Music]
over the next few days you can
experience this for yourself here at e3
in our playable demo and for you at home
here's a full gameplay sequence of
Assassin's Creed Odyssey thank you have
a grade III
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
such a beautiful island
ah
[Music]
Mykonos Island built from the corpses of
giants slain by the legendary Eve Atlas
Britney the note again regal bearing
misty us that's you
[Music]
we are a small but fierce group of
rebels who'd pay you handsomely to help
us overthrow our Athenian oppressors a
warrior named Theo Cleese fights with
them none who face them survive
please misty us our people are dying
signed Kira
[Music]
what did your informant tell you world
has already spread of you sinking those
ships there's a price on your head oh
that didn't take long
there's also world of Spartans landing
on Mykonos so I'm here to find Kira who
wants me to kill their place in Athenian
Ally who's at war with Sparta and don't
forget the bounty business as usual then
gods protect you Cassandra thanks for
nervous but they'll be too busy
protecting V Elise from me
Hey
mercenary this can't be good
you're chasing your own you want my head
come and take it
[Music]
you
[Music]
you really should have left me alone
yeah
[Music]
Barnabas was right Spartans have made
themselves right at home
I'm looking for Kira what do you want
with her
ha well mercenary who bears the eagle of
Zeus you got my message it said
something about paying me handsomely
mercenaries Athenians have enslaved
their people for too long
help us free Mykonos from their grasp
and you'll have more than meal and you
can carry I'm here to kill the oakley's
not go to war which is why I sent word
of a rebellion to you and Sparta my men
are ferocious in a ground assault but
we're outnumbered in the Okies fights
with the fury of Ares join us in battle
if you're half the warrior Kira says you
are we'll grind these Athenians into
dust
[Music]
all right Spartan I'll fight with you
but the kiss is mine to battle them
this isn't you either murder
your life ends today
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone and thank you for joining us
and thanks to everyone watching from
home to our teams it's an honor to work
with some of the best in the world
congratulations on the great show
[Applause]
I am man I am an uppity I am an
optimistic guy and I am particularly
excited about the future of technology
and the positive role games will play in
shaping our society to create these
games we need to work even more openly
with you the gamers because we know when
we do that together everything gets
better
so our greatest recycler very much
oh hi everybody welcome to the post-show
as promised that was an amazing
conference but we're not wasting any
time we're jumping right into it we're
gonna show live extensive gameplay of
the division
welcome back everyone we just watched
ubisoft's press conference at e3 2018
and we're back here to break down what
exactly we saw at that hour and a half
long press conference man there was a
lot to take in
so I'm joined again of course by my
friends tomorrow Callie Jake and who
there's a lot to unpack weird